[Music]
fire
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Avatar The Last
Airbender Netflix video there's a whole
bunch of announcements we'll break it
all down it's a lot of really good news
those of you that have been asking for a
brand new animated Avatar The Last
Airbender series with a different avatar
it sounds like your prayers have been
answered based on some of this news if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the avatar videos
I'll be doing bonus videos until the
brand new series premieres so just go
down the list of all the announcements
they just made Bryan Konietzko also made
some separate announcements earlier this
week too that I'll breakdown in this so
starting with a big stuff first number 5
Netflix just released a new trailer that
I attached the beginning of this for
Avatar The Last Airbender because it's
finally releasing the original series
inside the United States in a couple
weeks
this is obviously all part of their plan
to do the brand-new Avatar The Last
Airbender Netflix series it just build
hype for that because that's not gonna
premiere for a while here's the thing
though if you live outside the United
States the original series has been on
Netflix in most countries for a long
time the main reason why it's never been
available inside the US on streaming
platforms is because Nickelodeon and
Viacom who owned the brand thought that
it made way too much money from the DVD
and blu-ray market and they didn't want
to cannibalize the money that they were
making from those they just released
another special anniversary edition of
the blu-ray - also Viacom has been one
of the last major networks to join the
streaming revolution with a lot of its
content that's why you won't find any of
their other really major brands on
Netflix like spongebob that's all
changing in the next couple of years
Nickelodeon last year cite a major
production deal with Netflix for a bunch
of new content that they're creating
together for Netflix the brand-new
Avatar The Last Airbender series is kind
of part of that so for all the original
Avatar The Last Airbender episodes will
be released on Netflix May 15th as the
announcement said during that trailer
the brand-new Avatar The Last Airbender
series that they're making is way behind
on production though even before the
virus shut everyone down earlier this
year they weren't ready to start filming
as we had thought they had been there'd
be people last year who had said oh
they're gonna start filming in February
but then February came and went and
there was no news Brian can yetsko came
and was like yes sorry everybody we're
way way further behind on this than we
ever thought that we would be so just
given the new timeline in what's
happening with the virus the new series
probably won't be able to premiere till
at least late 2021 or even spring 2022
depending on whether or not they can get
their [ __ ] together before the end of
the year they made a couple
announcements about open casting calls a
long time ago they'll do that when
they're ready to start filming so you
might have a chance to actually star in
the new series but we won't find out
about that till way later this year 3
the new mega announcement that Brian can
yetsko made a couple of days ago was all
about the Avatar The Last Airbender
season 4
the mythical season 4 that was reported
a long time ago so quick history on
those rumors a long time ago there were
reports that they were going to do an
avatar book 4 but those plans had been
stopped because of work on the terrible
terrible live-action avatar the last
airbender movie so then just last year
in April Aron AHA's who was one of the
lead writers on the series that everyone
kind of points to as creating a lot of
the best Avatar stories posted a bunch
of tweets saying that they had discussed
doing a season four at one point then
and night came in they did that terrible
live-action movie then their plans
reverted to the original idea of ending
things at book 3 but then the network
came in and asked him to pitch his plans
for season 4 so then air Neha's detailed
what the story of his planned
quote-unquote season 4 would have been
and it's mostly in Azula Zuko arc about
the redemption of Azula and her getting
a similar arc to at Zuko got during
books 1 2 & 3
when he finally formally joined Team
avatar I did a whole video about that
Azula storyline so I'll link that at the
end of this but then earlier this week
Bryan can yetsko came out and did
another mega post about that planned
season 4 on all those rumors and within
that post he also talks about future
avatar series that they'll be doing too
so I know everybody wants to see more
animated series so I'll just read his
quote here he says I appreciate
everyone's interest but it's not
anywhere close to being true that there
was supposed to be a fourth season of
Avatar The Last Airbender despite what
you might have read on Twitter or
elsewhere so that's him addressing Aaron
Hawes's tweets Mike and I designed it to
be three
seasons from the very beginning when we
created it and pitched it to Nickelodeon
in the spring of 2002 a beginning a
middle and an end that's it this was the
plan long before there was ever a movie
and the fact that the movie happened had
no impact on us wrapping up the story
the way we wanted to I wouldn't have any
interest in watering down and prolonging
the story into an extraneous fourth
season over a decade ago and I don't
have any interest in doing that now nor
will I in the future
that's him referencing the brand-new
live-action Avatar The Last Airbender
Netflix series I'll talk about that in a
second - here's the part where he starts
talking about future avatar series that
they have not announced yet he goes on
to say but there will surely be more
stories in the avatar verse in a variety
of media for many years to come
we're working on a big one now that's
the live-action Netflix series and who
knows what will follow meaning that
they'll probably do other live-action
Avatar The Last Airbender stories like
Korra or future avatars after Korra and
if and when Mike and I ever get back to
making more animation in this world it
would be the story were most interested
in telling not the one everyone is
yelling at us to make so that's him just
confirming yes there will be more
animated Avatar The Last Airbender
series with different avatars that's how
we made the original for us first and
foremost and that's how the best art is
made again we greatly appreciate your
interest in enthusiasm please be patient
and you can stop tagging us now thanks
take care love Bryan so obviously people
have been hounding them for years about
this avatar Season four and what's going
on with other animated avatar the last
airbender series so next big thing - he
doesn't really say what that next
animated avatar the last airbender
series is going to be but i think
because they're kind of going through
the Avatar cycle fire air water the next
avatar would be an earthbender because
we had two avatars during the original
series the Avatar before Aang was a
firebender Roku we got most of his story
within the flashbacks than the Airbender
Avatar Aang because he was the main star
of that series then we had the
waterbender avatar in Korra during
Legend of Korra so the next avatar
series should arguably cover the story
of that next earthbender that becomes
the avatar after Korra winds up dying if
they want to complete
avatar cycle but go into the past
obviously avatar kyoshi would obviously
be that avatar she's pretty much the
most famous avatar within the mythology
that they haven't done a full story on
yet and if you're a big fan of the
avatar comics they just published a
brand new avatar kyoshi book and
supposedly there's gonna be some sequels
to that book so they are doing a lot of
avatar kyoshi stuff within the avatar
verse everyone let me know in the
comments though what do you want that
new avatar series to be about in
obviously number one the biggest thing
about the new Netflix Avatar The Last
Airbender series that they're in the
middle of making right now he reveals
that they have no plans to go beyond
Aang's defeat of Ozai and Zuko's
ascension to the throne as the new Fire
Lord there been a lot of you on my
avatar the last airbender videos who had
asked if they might do some of the story
of the avatar comics as part of the new
Netflix series because those cover the
story of team avatar and what happens to
them after the events at book 3 they
explain what happened to Azula after the
end of book 3 they explained what
happened to Zuko's mother they explained
what happened between Aang and Zuko in
the world in the things leading up to
the beginning of Legend of Korra they
did do some adult team avatar flashbacks
during Legend of Korra season 1 but they
still didn't quite answer all the
questions that people had about the
original team avatar members like what
happened to Sokka still one of the
biggest mysteries as of the end of
Legend of Korra we know a lot about what
happened to Aang what happened to Toph
what happened to Zuko but we don't know
a lot about what happened to Sokka I
will do videos for a lot of those
stories when we get closer to the new
Netflix series premiering but there will
be more avatar bonus videos in general
but hopefully this clarifies what
they're going to be doing in terms of
the story of the brand new avatar the
last airbender Netflix series I think
there was just some confusion when they
first made the announcement about the
new Netflix series saying that they'd be
expanding going deeper on the characters
what that means is is that when they're
retelling the story of the original
avatar the last airbender series they're
just gonna add extra character moments
within what you would consider the
original episode so like they do the
book 1 episodes but they're twice as
long because it's been way more along
with each character in each of the
scenes so there will be some new
material some new scenes added two
episodes that weren't in the original
series it'll be fun to try and spot
those when we actually get the episodes
so if you have any big quest
about this or any special requests for
avatar videos just let me know in the
comments below my next video will be for
the brand-new Clone Wars Revenge of the
Sith episode it was amazing best episode
of the Clone Wars ever as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see that when I posted everyone
click here for that full video on this
story of Avatar The Last Airbender
season 4 and click here for my brand new
spider-man 3 Tom Holland clip thank you
so much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]